[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
drew brees joining us on the program
drew how are you today
you're doing great dad how are you
are you are you taking a walk is that
your exercise this morning
yeah this is this is uh this is kind of
get the day started you know clear my
head
i'm in uh i'm in greenwich connecticut
we just uh we finished doing the studio
show last night for
football night in america so this is my
morning walk before
i head out of town what do people say to
you on the street
ah
i get some looks i stopped by whole
foods to grow
like some oatmeal and some fruit and i
had a couple people
want to talk football
ask me ask me what happened to the
buffalo bills yesterday
you know or
whoever their favorite team is so yeah
there's there's a lot of that you know i
got to put the analyst hat on a lot just
in my daily lifetime what happens when
you've had a bad game like ryan
tannehill threw four interceptions
is it bad to watch that film or is it
better to not watch film
oh man it it it stinks it's just one of
those things you got to do just swallow
it you know but
um
at the same time shoot you know missed
opportunity for them right you know
that's a game they should win
um you know crummy weather so you got to
play the game a little bit differently
but they certainly had their chances i
still think they're a team
to beat just because i think their
defense is pretty good but they're gonna
have to figure some things out on
offense without their counter
well it's one of those games where you
go wait the texans are doing what to the
titans i mean it it feels like every
week there's at least two of these games
how do you explain it
the nfl
that's right
that's why people that's why that's why
people love the nfl because each week
you have no idea and and every game
really comes down to about seven or
eight plays about seven or eight moments
or situations and whoever handles those
right wins and and whoever doesn't
doesn't and regardless of records i
think anytime you play divisional games
throw records out the window for the
first three quarters those are typically
hard tough football games and then
usually the better team finds a way to
win it in the fourth quarter or pull
away but you let a team hang around that
you shouldn't
and it's the nfl look out they'll beat
you
what would you do if you're uh ben
roethlisberger
what do you mean
short term long term
come back next season
yeah i mean look
if he plays if he can if he continues to
play like he did last night you know
um
it you know i i think as a as a veteran
as a veteran quarterback i think the
thing that you
the thing that you battle is
look you have so much experience so much
knowledge so much wisdom from from all
the football that you've played
now it becomes harder each and every
week
just from a physical perspective to
care for your body to care for your arm
to care for all the things that just
start popping up you know from a health
perspective and and get to sunday you
know that was kind of always the thing
is man get to sunday as healthy as you
can
because up here like
you've got it
i mean you know exactly what everybody's
doing there's never a defense you're
gonna see that you haven't seen before
you don't have an answer for but it's
just that that weekly grind i think not
just physically but
uh just you know you take on a lot of
stress too because you know you're
responsible for so much but
man as long as he's having fun playing
at a high level and play as long as you
can but how frustrating is that that you
have all the answers to the test
but you
you might not be able to complete the
test
well
look i i again i think i think he played
well last night you know and i don't
know i don't know how his you know ben's
always been one of those guys that you
you feel like is getting beat up quite a
bit you know
or at least uh
that's kind of always what's reported um
so you know but but as long as he's
having fun and
and doing a high level and
you know feeling like he still has
something to to prove and chase
um then man why not why not play listen
last night if
if if the steelers have you know minker
fitzpatrick and tj watt and
you know joe hayden i think that's
it's a different game you know i think
defensively they it ended up playing a
little better but uh it's a fun game to
watch what do you make of justin herbert
so far
i think he's stud i think he is going to
be
one of the great players in this league
for a very long time
uh he's got all the physical ability i
mean
freakish physical ability you know arm
talent
athletic ability
um
i think he's
got
as many intangibles as he does the
physical traits as well from the
leadership perspective and just his
poise
and his and his intellect so
he
he can be one of the best for a very
long time
what's been the biggest challenge for
you making this uh transition from
football to analyst
well i mean it's uh
it's it's it's a different skill set
you know it's using different muscles
i'd say the biggest challenge honestly
is
first off broadcasting and in studio
work are completely different anyway
um
you know broadcasting to me is is kind
of like playing the game which is a lot
of fun i prepare the same way i watch
film the same way i mean i think about
how i would be attacking
the the opposing team or the opposing
defense
the exact same way as if i was actually
going to go out there and play
quarterback and then it's just a matter
of being up to articulate that to
the fans or those listening and watching
and you know try to put them in your
shoes
as a player
you know you go in studio and it's it's
uh
it's it's much quicker you know you have
a lot more to get through in a very
short amount of time you're really
trying to give a synopsis of what
happened throughout the entire day
and the broadcasting is college football
and the in studio is nfl football so you
feel like you have to have this
knowledge base
of kind of the general landscape of both
so that makes it difficult and then i
get to go broadcast an nfl game on on
thursday night in new orleans so
it's a little bit everything all kind of
thrown into a very short amount of time
but that's another thing is you you and
mike trico are going to have the game on
thursday night it'll be the bills and
the saints and do you
do you prepare
so you're buffalo going against the
saints in what you would do as as well
as the saints going against buffalo and
what you would do
if you were playing
yeah yeah i mean that's
i guess i've i've watched i've already
watched a bunch of film but but as i
watch
they continue to watch
more games you know i almost develop a
game plan in my mind
as to how i would attack
you know each defense or if i'm in each
offense
these are these are where my matchups
are this is how
i want to play this game this is what i
think the keys to victory are
so then when you get in the in the
broadcast booth and you begin watching
the game unfold
in a lot of cases it it plays out the
way that i would have envisioned
now
listen crazy things happen right and you
have to be ready to react but man that's
what we love about football and that's
that's what's fun is is that you never
really know what's going to happen
but you know based on your knowledge
base and your experience you're able to
articulate those moments in those those
situations for people
and then you're going to be honored
on thursday night
what's that going to entail
yeah uh well you know my
my last time in the dome uh was was
unfortunately with no fans
you know all of last season was was
virtually with no fans
so it's been a while since
i've been in the dome with
you know the the screaming who dat
nation you know and all that energy
um so this would be uh this would be
this would be an incredible moment to
get back in front of the who dat nation
and
um you know obviously under under kind
of weird circumstances since i'm there
to broadcast the game but
um it'll be great to to feel that one
more time
i know you're doing some things with uh
crown royals if you want to let people
uh in on what you're doing
well yeah tonight i'm actually gonna be
in new orleans uh
me and deuce mcallister are gonna be in
an event with a bunch of hospitality
workers military members as part of
crown royals generosity fund where
they're going to donate a million
dollars
to different organizations throughout
the year to support hospitality workers
and and military members so we deuce and
i each represent
a different group so i represent the
louisiana hospitality foundation deuce
represents the bastian community of
resilience and so we're going to have a
little competition at this concert
uh to continue to raise money and raise
awareness
for these these groups and so that uh we
can continue to support them especially
coming off of cover 19 where many of
them were affected negatively so this
would be a lot of fun tonight and um
we're asking people to go going to my
twitter at drew brees retweet the tweet
that i um sent out a few a few days ago
because that helps generate more
uh money for the louisiana
hospitality workers foundation so thank
you
good to see you how far are you gonna
walk by the way
it always ends up being about four or
five miles
but man the leaves are changing color
yeah this is kind of nice you don't you
don't you don't get this down south or
on the west coast at all you know so you
gotta gotta take all this in while you
can when's the last time you throw a
football
oh it's you with
i throw one left-handed all the time
i kind of developed that habit
like four years ago when my kids were
getting older and every time i get home
they're like dad throw to us dad drunk
train somebody
i just finished throwing 100 balls at
[ __ ] this from here left-handed so i
don't wear this right arm out i actually
i've gotten pretty good with the left
here dan
better watch out man come back question
mark
question mark question mark question
mark we'll see
have fun this week uh always great to
talk to you happy thanksgiving
all right you as well there thanks
that's uh drew brees